part-1 when they say show that something
is a solution this is actually a really
important point what does it mean that
something is a solution of an equation
how would you define that like something
is a solution because what yeah it works
a solution means this thing will
actually be a true statement okay so
therefore all that's required is to
actually just test it out so the way I
would do this is for part one I would
say the left-hand side equals and I'm
gonna substitute in x equals a okay so
let's just quickly do that one minus a
squared what am I going to get here to
eight so all right minus 2 a 1 minus a
squared agreed that's the same thing
just written in reverse order so that's
0 as required
so the only thing that I could do to
this line to make it less of a fudge is
to write this because apart from that
that is a direct rewriting of that line
up there with x equals a right I suppose
you could say when x equals a the left
hand side equals that are but um I I
think it is patently obvious that when
you subtract something from itself
you're good it's gonna be zero so that's
fine that's okay
part two so I want to show you that this
is true now when I have a look at this
line here I have an idea in my head of
what to do with it but I wonder what
jumps out at you like where would you
even begin to try and prove that this
was the case any suggestions expand what
okay so when you have a look at this and
this can you submit is there so many of
the same pieces right both of them are
equal to zero
both of those are quadratics in X right
you said there's x squared terms and X
and another constant term if this is
just a version of this with the X
Squared's sort of disentangled okay so
why I'm just going to need to expand
this guy and write it this is general
form okay if you recognize it
here is your ax squared it just happens
that your a is 2a oh here's your BX
right and then here's your C this whole
thing that's the constant term do you
need me to do that or are you okay for
us to we can move on okay so it's just
algebra that's just some expansion so
having proven that this is the case the
other root is that view
okay sure so
hmm so so you got some choices here
right how much is this question worth is
our 203 do - yeah
so I'm actually I'm gonna give you a
second okay because if I'm thinking
about this question correctly there's at
least three ways you could do this
question the reason why I'm pausing and
wanting you guys to have a go is I don't
know which is the fastest yet I'd
actually have to give them a go and then
I'd look at them like oh this is five
lines this is eight or whatever okay
let's just throw out there so one
suggestion was summon product of routes
that's an idea what else could you
possibly do that again core JT formula
because if you know one route well we
know that the quadratic form is a way to
find routes that's also fine what else
could you do and those are only two
ideas here to division yes you yeah yeah
such a talent for like what is the most
inefficient way that I it's like after I
have to kill this Flyers anyone got a
bazooka okay
sure why not okay so what I'm going to
suggest is noticing that we just were
asked to get this thing into general
form okay I'm going to suggest that some
unproductive roots is a good idea
because someone product of roots some
and product are very lean very easily
stated things right because this is just
going to be - be on a this is just going
to be C on a right so let me give you 30
or 60 seconds to have a play with that
I don't even tell you what they are cuz
I think that would give it away and see
what emerges and see if you can get the
answer you got some employment of roots
now because they're quite easy to work
out I wouldn't be surprised if you just
worked out what they were okay
however I'm actually going to suggest
you because overall it's an important
strategy even though here it doesn't
make that much of a difference you
should always be searching for a quicker
way if you've got like oh I've got five
things I could try if you can work out
which one's the most use taught first
that's a good idea isn't it now have a
look at the result they're trying to
prove right
do you notice if you look carefully at
this term do you notice that you pretty
much have all those pieces nestled
inside the previous part have a look for
example see that one plus a squid it's
it's literally directly above it's right
there okay and the two a that looks
suspicious as well right now this is C
and this is a the coefficient is squared
so therefore I'm thinking this is going
to be more useful to me like it's a more
direct path there's nothing wrong with
working out alpha plus beta but we all
know that it's not like you've got time
to sit around twiddling your thumbs in
an extension exam okay so therefore I'm
just going to go straight to the product
of roots and cross my fingers okay so
alpha times beta equals here comes C on
a negative a 1 plus a squared on to a oh
great now it's not a bad idea to start
simplifying things here but I don't need
to just yet because there's actually
something in this equation that I
haven't quite simplified I've done the
right hand side but what's the left hand
side yes so alfred via right are the two
roots but I already know what one of the
roots is it's a right that's what's why
we did this in part one so therefore
this left hand side I'm going to write
as a times theta sorry all right
like I'm just it doesn't matter which
ones which okay just labels so you can
see here this is like the easiest two
marks in the whole paper look at the
left and right hand side just divide
both through by hey cancel cancel the
other root that's what beta is is minus
that on that as required okay now I said
that if there's just two marks in the
paper but the the actual number
crunching via or algebra is easy but
seeing that you need to use this and
then do something to the left hand side
you don't do that very often do you
okay that's not common the question is
trying to push you in this direction
have a look what is the clue the
question gives you look back right back
to the start
yeah like they didn't that's weird isn't
it when do you ever get asked to do
something like that and the fact that
it's part one putt-putt 3 should
indicate you all right like this will be
useful for me later ok